after 8 news now first told you about
the license being suspended at heights
funeral home in henderson many of you
reached out joe mohler looked into what
you can do if you have a complaint about
a funeral home he joins us live with
more details and some good advice hi joe
hey there people have had concerns or
complaints well before the suspension
happened earlier this week now whether
it's this location or another funeral
home we learned that you can actually
file a complaint on the state's funeral
board website now we spoke to several
people who are now working to get loved
ones removed from heights after learning
about the violations and the suspension
tanya saletto says she was told by casa
de paz funeral home that her mother's
remains were at heights after planning
the arrangements earlier this week after
she heard my story she contacted casa de
paz who then told her they never sent
her mother to heights
with casa de boss i was able to have a
service for my mother
i was going to have a service arranged
services
now
i have to pay more money to have my
mother embalmed so i can id my mother
because at this moment i'm not trusting
anybody
in the state of nevada there is a board
of funeral and cemetery services on the
website you can file a complaint with
the forms that look like this on the
site you can also view prior
disciplinary actions taken at funeral
homes we learned a funeral home or
crematory is usually inspected once
every two years by the state there is
one inspector for the whole state of
nevada now back out here live the
executive director told me they are
overseeing the suspension at heights the
business must turn in the list of the
decedents they have here at the facility
by the to the state by tomorrow the
remains must be buried cremated or
transferred to another location within
the next month reporting live in
henderson joe mullen 8 news now joe